clients here awesome are you ready Oh  ready let's do this ah you have a little  thank you mm-hmm yeah and also oh my  glasses yeah okay thanks how are you  good  tired yeah the baby had a rough night  last night but you know that's how it  goes I don't know how you do it you just  do honey  yeah there's no school today it's Monday  I know what are we gonna do I want two  opinions please  yeah are you going to work you're coming  with Mama today yeah if I was a mom I'd  posey a stay-at-home mom my mom was a  stay-at-home mom so I just wanted to  check in with everyone and see where  we're all that sorry excuse me  hey babe what's up I'm sorry I'm trying  every class no I can't  okay okay the tutitu I love you yes I'm  in here I'm humping don't come in do in  look up here  a beach how we're all going salsa  dancing and Gravatt drinks after work  sounds like fun but I gotta get home  maybe next time huh yeah thanks for the  invite of course